space so they say is the final frontier
and historically wherever humans have
explored what they thought was uncharted
territory war and conflict have never
been far behind it's one small step for
man
one
diaper
and while the last century may be seen
as the golden age of space exploration
modern society is almost completely
reliant on space technology which is why
any war up there could have huge
consequences
back down here the opening battles of a
world war iii
are likely to be completely silent
because they would play out in outer
space
[Music]
space is pretty much infinite and
technically it starts only 62 miles
above our heads on earth that's about
the same distance as driving from here
at the royal observatory in london to
oxford
space starts here the carmen line
anything above that is quickly becoming
a key area for on-earth conflicts
all roger liftoff and the clock has
started now the militarization of space
is nothing new
[Music]
space warfare can be traced back to 1957
when the soviet union launched sputnik
the first ever satellite
the following year the americans
launched a satellite of their own
explorer one
that triggered the cold war space race
leading to the first man in space in
1961 and the first men on the moon in
1969
but even before these historic
achievements we were testing our most
powerful weapons in space atomic and
thermonuclear bombs
between 1951 and 1958 the u.s conducted
166 atmospheric tests and the soviet
union conducted 82.
two treaties signed in the 1960s put a
stop to nuclear weapons being tested or
placed in space
but it was not the end of space warfare
in the 1970s and early 1980s the ussr
and the us continued to develop space
technology largely focusing on
satellites and anti-satellite weapons
more on that later
in 1984 u.s president ronald reagan
announced the strategic defense
initiative a missile system that would
shield the us from nuclear attack
but the so-called star wars program
never really went anywhere over fears it
could violate the already tenuous pact
with the ussr hinging on mutually
assured destruction the guarantee that
both sides could destroy each other that
helped maintain peace
the 1991 gulf war could be thought of as
the first space war no it was not fought
in space but the use of gps and
satellite information was vital in the
u.s driving iraqi troops out of kuwait
and since then the military use of gps
high-speed communication in the field
and spying have all developed
significantly thanks to satellites
then there was space force
part of the united states armed forces
its aim is to oversee all things space
for the american military hinting that
there is much more to come from space
warfare in the future
while it would be fun to talk galactic
battle cruisers and death stars future
wars in space would actually be all
about satellites not just our modern
military but our modern world depends
on the thousands of satellites that fly
above us they are essential you probably
use them every single day there are
thousands in orbit at any given time and
they help us predict the weather watch
tv get directions speak to friends on
the phone they could even be helping you
watch this right now
there are multiple different orbits
around the earth that these satellites
sit in
first up you have low earth orbit this
is where the international space station
sits and where high resolution satellite
imagery is taken from
medium earth orbit is vital for gps the
tech that powers both directions on your
phone as well as keeping track of jumbo
jet planes
higher orbits like geostationary polar
and sun synchronous orbits are used for
tracking weather and helping
telecommunications
all of these are vital to the military
every modern military
whether it's nato states or potential
adversaries like a china
both depend on space satellites but also
if push came to shove would try and take
that away from the other side satellites
and the technologies that back them up
can become targets themselves
why nature included space in its article
5 principle which means that any attack
to from or within space can fall under
that category and trigger the alliance's
response you have to think of it in
terms of
a war on earth that includes space so
you're not going to get a space what
happens by itself
it's going to be something that happens
in relation to conflict on earth as well
for example most recently russia has
jammed ukrainian gps signals used for
navigation and mapping
so how could satellites become caught up
in a space war there are two main ways
either cyber attacks or anti-satellite
missiles shot from earth anti-satellite
missiles target and destroy satellites
in orbit simple enough a lot of
countries have anti-satellite capability
but they've only really been used in
tests by militaries to destroy their own
old out-of-use satellites this is not
without risks of its own though
space debris is extremely dangerous and
could take out other satellites or
spaceships it's moving with such speed
it can be the size of your fist but take
out an entire space station because it's
moving you know past the the speed of a
missile so for example a piece from the
2007 uh chinese enter satellite tests
some pieces of debris are still going
around the orbits and it meant that the
international space station the iss had
to dodge a piece of debris
from that test in 2007 and 2021
the other more likely route a space war
could go down is cyber attacks if you
could hack into a satellite you suddenly
have a huge advantage over your enemy
you could cut their gps their
communication you could send false
information and you could spy on their
every move
and this is probably the closest to star
wars we get there is also the
possibility of satellites spying on or
even attacking each other in recent
years we've been hearing about
russian chinese and american satellites
and
dancing with each other
doing close maneuvers
and spying on the communications if you
can grab a satellite to repair it
that also means you can grab another
nation satellite so what we call this
it's so called dual use technology and
it means that technology can be used for
civil purposes such as the repair or
manufacturing of satellites but it could
also mean that you could use it for sort
of more dangerous maneuvers
so how does space war actually pan out
when we were asked to paint a scene of
what a
opening day of a world war three between
the us and a china might look like
it began with a series of moves
that took place in the dark so to speak
that's everything from um
blinding lasers directed energy uh going
after the spy satellites to other
satellites coming to life and crashing
into key communication node
network satellites
to potentially anti-satellite weapons
rockets being fired into space all of
which sounds like science fiction lasers
rockets hitting satellites but each one
of these have been tested
ten seconds of course it isn't just
governments venturing into space three
two
one we are headed to space
private companies like virgin galactic
and blue origin are taking major steps
in the space industry as well as
ferrying their respective billionaire
owners into space and back again
but it's elon musk's spacex who is the
clear leader here
spacex has major military contracts and
works closely with nasa taking
astronauts to the iss and delivering
equipment with rockets
and the company has even had a small
taste of space warfare
payload deploy confirmed
after the start of the ukraine war elon
musk activated spacex's starlink
satellite over ukraine providing
receivers so people could access their
internet service
russia then targeted starlink in a cyber
attack
satellite warfare is not the only
potential type of future conflict as
humans move towards developing bases on
the moon and traveling to mars it's not
very hard to imagine conflicts over
territory the kind of warfare we're all
too familiar with here on earth
what does that scramble for resources in
outer space look like
is it completely cooperative
or
maybe it looks like
something equivalent to the 15 to 1700s
where the european powers equally had
this sort of scramble for resources and
new worlds so to speak that they'd
opened up
which
one
had a huge consequence to the people
that were already there
but also
brought
conflict
back with them
what does that look like for example
when you've got two different powers or
maybe
private companies that represent them
that each claim
some kind of multi-billion or even
multi-trillion dollar resource i think
we are still some time away from from
how um
that will actually look like but i think
it goes again to to show that we do need
rules and regulations in place for when
that technology eventually arrives
because the
kind of division of resources uh in
space is sure to come up um at some
point in the future um
and it
depends how how we decide to govern over
that
but perhaps there's also hope for a
better future space exploration was
supposed to be a giant leap for mankind
and not just a place for war
and there remains hope that maybe just
maybe the new generation of galactic
explorers can throw off the shackles of
their ancestors the colonisers and find
peace in the stars
space and its assets are already
implicated in terrestrial warfare so
it's just a question of whether it's
going to become a domain for warfighting
itself most of the science fiction
visions of conflict in space
they're not going to happen at least
during year in my lifetime politics is
the art of the possible nothing is set
in stock nothing is inevitable but if
there is a major war between
uh significant space powers in the
future then it is highly likely that
there will be some conflict in space as
a result of that
you'll be woven into battles at sea
battles on the land battles in the air
and that's because those systems whether
it's a warship whether it's a tank
whether it's a commando in the field
they're relying upon networks in space